hello everyone I came across the most
interesting article on The Wall Street
Journal
well not exactly on The Wall Street
Journal but through Magnus Coulson's
Twitter page they tweeted about it you
know it's it's like they wanted me to
see this article and make a video about
it so so I decided yeah okay I'll do it
and it's quite an interesting article
it's about this guy max Deutsch and he
describes himself as an obsessive
learner he kind of creates a challenge
for himself that he will master any
skill within within a month so he
mastered quite a lot of skills he
mastered the Rubik's the Rubik's Cube he
was able to solve it in under 17 seconds
he mastered the standing backflip you
know he didn't just manage to do it he
it's like he mastered it he managed to
draw a portrait of himself you know a
self-portrait and it was really
realistic so he really sets a lot of
challenges for himself and in one
month's time he achieves them so the
final challenge and the hardest one will
be to train one month and to be able to
defeat the world champion Magnus Carlsen
in a game of chess so of course this he
knew himself that this would be quite a
task and and I really enjoyed that
Magnus Carlsen decided to do this you
know to indulge mr. Max's endeavors to
you know to overcome any challenge he
set for himself and well max don't you
decide I saw that he couldn't really
learn how to play chess in one month
that good to be able to defeat Magnus
Carlsen so he decided that he would have
to learn to play chess like a machine
and that's easier said than done and he
took I will put a link in the
description below where you can read the
entire article from The Wall Street
Journal but basically he created a
program and he took like 1,000 chess
positions great chess positions and he
wanted to create a nog an algorithm
which would allow him to think like the
computer or as he puts it a very slow
computer but nevertheless he couldn't
really see so far ahead or you know
calculate billions of positions and
second but at least he could find a good
candidate moves now one thing that
bothers me with this article is that
they began their match before
Max's algorithm was finished so it's
quite quite you know they should have
they should have waited for the
algorithm to finish because now they
just played a normal game but still I
decided to show you the game because
after the match max doe asked a cost and
if he would be interested in a rematch
when max finishes his algorithm and
Carlson said yeah sure so in case a
rematch does occur you will have an
insight into Max's chess skills from the
previous match so yeah
that being said like I said be sure to
read the article the link will be in the
description below so you know you can
check it out there's a bunch of photos
there a very cool video and also you can
check the game they're in in PGM so max
has the white pieces and we have E 4 E 5
Knight to f3 knight c6 and Bishop to b5
so max dodge goes for the rural opus and
it's it's not very clear if max Deutsch
really knows that this is the real opus
Knight G to e7 the co-ceo defense by
Carlsen and even though Carlsen I mean
he Carson is probably like 99.9% sure
that he's not going to lose this game
but still he goes for for a peculiar
defense just in case you know who knows
maybe max dodge has some photographic
memory maybe he memorized all the good
positions from the real opus so you know
of course your defense is definitely a
good way to go and the Carlsen couldn't
really prepare for his opponent so he's
he's you know shooting in blind
we have castles by max g6 now d4 he
captures on d4 Knight captures on d4 and
Bishop to g7 now with a double attack on
the knight on d4 Bishop to e3 max
protects the night cause and castles and
Knight to c3 d6 by Carlsen preparing to
develop the light square bishop and here
we have a first inaccuracy it's not it's
not a blunder by max simply Knight to d5
doesn't really it
she've anything for a white sure he
wants to trade down pieces but a normal
uh normal continuation here would be
something like Queen to d2 you know
connecting your rooks and developing the
Queen something an experienced player
would probably do instantly but okay if
you went for ninety five Carson captured
we have eight characters on d5 and now
Knight to e5 max goes for rook to e1 and
cause someplace Knight to g4 now
bothering this strong dark square Bishop
and Queen to f3 by Max and this is
already a weird weird position for white
cross and immediately jumps with Queen
to h4 threatening checkmate here on h2
and the best the best move for white
here would be something like Queen to g3
but then you just capture capture and
after Knight captures Bishop F captures
on e3 it's a you do have to capture with
the F pawn if you capture with the rook
you lose the night as the bishop is
attacking the knight so after half
captures on e3
black is much better here White's pawn
structure is hideous and this would be
no problem for Carlsen but unfortunately
after Queen to h4 and max played h3 even
though you know he probably did learn a
lot of chess in one month but he still
he doesn't have that tactics alarm
developed yet so Carson simply captures
the Bishop Knight captures and here max
doesn't capture with the Queen he
captures sorry he doesn't capture with
the F pawn he captures with the Queen
and Bishop captures on d4 so already not
the best position for max he's down a
piece Queen to d2 now Bishop captures on
b2 attacking the rook rook to be one
Bishop to e5 [ __ ] rook to be four now
with an attack on the Queen
Carson plays Queen to f6 obviously
threatening Bishop to c3 but Bishop to
d3 by max bishop the c3 now now pinning
everything pink both rooks and the Queen
Queen to f4 and Max offers the exchange
of Queens of course Carlsen accepts this
Queen captures rook captures and now
grabbing the whole rook and
one Bishop captures and how max is down
to sorry rook and the peace so this is
only a matter of time before Coulson
ends this c4 Bishop to b4 g4 was played
and there should be seven getting the
rooks into the game Bishop d2 rook rook
goes here c5 attacking the rook now an
exchange of rook occurs rock captures
Bishop captures and Bishop captures and
g4 King g3 now Bishop three to f3 white
doesn't really have anything to hope for
here he's done so much material Bishop
captures on c4 King g4 f I would check
Bishop captures now h5 first King g3 now
recapture King F to Bishop to a for now
locking in the King so he can go
anywhere and the rook will come down to
check made him King g1 was played rook
e8 check King f2 a rookie to check King
F one rook captures king he won now
Bishop to e3 King D one Bishop to d3 and
there is no escaping checkmate now
whatever white plays max played King to
e1 and constant finish the game with
rook to e1 with checkmate so yeah I mean
max didn't really play a great game here
for first nine moves were definitely
solid than that
nice to defy move was unnecessary but
then later of course as he doesn't have
his tactics alarm developed yet he
started blundering pieces but
nevertheless I decided to show this game
because I do hope that a rematch will
occur and that Max dodge will have his
algorithm ready because you know
everyone in the world is trying to make
the machines think like humans and I'm
really interested to see if max would be
able to figure out some sort of an
algorithm so a human can think like a
machine while playing chess whether this
will happen or or won't we'll just have
to see if if max continues with his
pursuit of this interesting algorithm
but you know time will tell
so yeah in case that happens
you have you have clear you know site
into into Max's abilities before his
algorithm was completed so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Fadi Nara Steven
Miller and the Mickey grammatical for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here once again do check out the
link in the description below to check
out the entire article from The Wall
Street Journal and I do hope to see most
of you in the stream today so yeah thank
you for watching and I will see you soon